[Musique]
lundi 23 mars 2031
vous arrivez au travail il est 9 heures
on vous présente
teddy votre nouveau collègue des
ressources humaines teddy qui s'est mis
sur son 31 pour son premier jour a déjà
en tête tous les cv et tous les
historiques de l'entreprise est fin prêt
à commencer sa journée
je vous propose de lever la main ceux
qui pensent que d'ici 15 à 20 ans nous
aurons des collègues de travail pour que
l'aic de travail des robots pas mal de
main levée je vous remercie
je vous repose à présent de lever la
main ceux qui sont enthousiastes face à
cette idée beaucoup moins demain d'un
côté on sait que ça va arriver mais d'un
autre on encore très peu aujourd'hui à
l'accepter je vais donc vous présenter à
travers trois histoires un antidote pour
mieux appréhender mieux prendre à bras
le corps cette révolution technologique
qui élit à et qui on verra en fait est
déjà la première histoire je présente
fabien 39 en jardinière son compte
depuis plus de 14 ans en province fabien
réalise essentiellement des prestations
de tentes sur des grands jardins ce qui
lui prend en moyenne deux heures
ces trois derniers mois fabien s'est
projeté sur son métier qui commence à
être impactée par l'arrivée de la
tondeuse autonome capable de gravir des
pentes de plus de 20% et d'éviter tous
types d'obstacles comme des racines
durant ces trois mois il s'est passé
trois étapes dans sa tête
tout d'abord c'est ridicule cette
tondeuse autonomes ces gadgets quand je
vois des terrains tout cabossé que
jetons jamais une machine n'arrivera à
gérer cela puis il a fait preuve de
curiosité et il a expérimenté lui-même
cette technologie et il est passé de ces
ridicules assez dangereux car si mes
clients apprennent ce qu'on ait fait
capable de faire cette technologie alors
ils vont en acheter
et j'aurais de moins
moins de clients enfin il a plutôt
décidé d'agir de prendre à bras le corps
cette nouvelle technologie
aujourd'hui fabien réalise toujours des
prestations de deux heures pour le même
prix mais il a considérablement augmenté
le niveau de sa prestation
car en plus de la tente qui est
désormais effectué par une tondeuse
autonomes dont il a fait lui-même
l'acquisition il réalise de son côté la
coupe des arbres des et des rosiers et
propose des nouveaux aménagements dont
le jardin fabien donc monter en
compétences en développant davantage sa
dextérité sa créativité
les devenus plus compétitifs que ses
confrères il envisage même de recruter
un collaborateur est une autre tondeuse
autonome bref son business se porte bien
et a un bel avenir devant lui il n'y a
pas que les travaux manuels qui vont
être impactés par l'irs emilie 42 ans
est à la tête d'un cabinet comptable et
elle et ses confrères sont souvent
pointés du doigt comme travaillant sur
un métier en voie de disparition car la
saisie comptable sera bientôt automatisé
par lire l'analyse même peut-être et ça
emilie elle le sait très bien
la saisie comptable comme toute routine
wii sera en effet automatisé par l'ia
mais quand fabien vont elles elles ne
souhaitent pas bien sûr que demain ses
clients se passe de ses services et
souscrivent auprès d'un comptable
virtuel bien moins cher mais plus rapide
qu'elle du coup à son tour elle décide
d'agir de prendre à bras le corps cette
nouvelle technologie est d'intégrer dès
aujourd'hui des techniques diar pour
automatiser ses routines afin derrière
de pouvoir dégager davantage de temps
auprès de ses collaborateurs
collaboratrice afin que ces derniers
puissent être plus présent auprès de
leurs clients pour qu'ils puissent voir
plus des changes pour qu'ils puissent
aborder des sujets qu aujourd'hui ne
peuvent pas abordé par manque de temps
comme la gestion de leur patrimoine la
recherche de fonds bref plus des changes
plus de relations humaines et une fine
et plus d'épanouissement pour ses
collaborateurs
l'antidote que je vous propose est celui
qu'on utilise et fabien emilie afin que
leur métier ne soit pas en voie de
disparition mais bien d'évolution cet
antidote il prend la forme de deux
étapes une première étape que va sans
effort passé la majorité des entreprises
c'est d'utiliser l'ia comme tout autre
outil informatique pour automatiser ses
routines afin derrière d'augmenter leur
productivité
c'est le côté aujourd'hui très attractif
de l'ia dans le monde de l'entreprise
mais aussi très dangereux car si
l'entreprise se limite uniquement à
cette première étape
alors oui il y a va détruire plus
d'emplois qu'elle ne va en faire évoluer
car un gain de productivité qu'est ce
que c'est dans ce cas là c'est la
capacité de produire plus avec moins de
ressources humaines qu'on va donc
supprimer
et c'est aussi dangereux pour
l'entreprise ont elles mêmes car quand
toutes les entreprises auront
automatisée avec l'ia leur routine pour
baisser leurs coûts mais ce l'entreprise
qui arriveront à se différencier à
sortir leur épingle du jeu
ce seront celles qui auront investi dans
l'humain ce sont les entreprises qui
pour le même prix arriveront à proposer
une meilleure prestation comme emilie
fabien grâce à de l'humain une meilleure
relation client par exemple une offre de
meilleure qualité plus innovantes grâce
à l'humain c'est ma deuxième étape ne
pas voir lié à comme cet adversaire qui
peut détruire des emplois mais plutôt
comme cette opportunité pour d
automatiser le travail humain via
l'automatisation des routines montée en
compétence s'élever dans son
intelligence humaine via notamment les
fameux soap ce qu'ils la créativité la
dextérité pour reprendre l'exemple de
fabien la conscience sociale le travail
collaboratif pour emilie montée d'ankang
compétences pour élever sa prestation en
y rajoutant de l'humain et une fille née
cet important s'épanouir davantage au
travail sur des tâches plus valorisante
pour illustrer cette complémentarité que
nous devons rechercher avec l'ia je
finirai ma présentation avec une
anecdote est une innovation limougeaude
je vous présente dingli vous la pelouse
bon jeu unique
bonjour tout le monde je suis super
content petit mes invités bonjour line
be in by pour ceux qui ne la connaissent
pas est une pro botte de service conçue
et construite par la société sac droid
qui siège à seulement quelques rudes ici
il ya plusieurs mois
ils ont réalisé une expérimentation
pendant trois jours dans un aéroport où
ils ont évité ligne bis au niveau de
l'accueil à répondre à des questions
très simples du style où sont les
arrivées
où sont les toilettes ou son départ
malheureusement le premier jour et
dirigeants de l' aéroport n'avait pas du
tout communiquer concernant cette
expérimentation auprès des gens de
l'accueil qui sont les personnes
aujourd'hui qui répondent à ces
questions
du coup vous l'imaginez ces personnes
l'ont très mal pris naturellement quand
elles ont vu arriver ligne bis et elles
sont passées de ces ridicules assez
dangereux cette expérimentation
car s'il nbi fait bien son job à la fin
de la semaine je suis à la porte et bien
le troisième et dernier jour lorsqu'ils
sont venus récupérer lindy les personnes
de l'accueil s'était attaché à ce rebond
elle était triste de le voir partir
il ya même une salariée qui a dit ah
mince je vais devoir à nouveau faire ce
travail de robots ont trois jours allait
passer de ces ridicules c'est dangereux
c'est évident qu'il faille un robot qui
répandent 50 fois par jour à la question
où sont les toilettes ce qui me permet à
moi de maféré des tâches
alors certes plus stressante mais à plus
forte valeur ajoutée comme la perte des
bagages
j'ai raté mon avion qui nécessitent
derrière de développer davantage son
empathie son adaptabilité sa
communication habile l'antidote on
synthèse deux étapes
dans une première étape identifié dès
aujourd'hui qu'elles sont dans votre
travail c'est routine que pour à
automatiser lia et puis dans un second
temps quelles sont ses compétences
humaines sur lesquels vous allez pouvoir
monter en puissance pour ajouter donc de
l'humain dans votre travail mais une
fille née également vous épanouir
davantage je vous remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]